all right
[Music]
hey everybody it's Monday once again
doesn't it seem like we were just doing
this
time is flying by yeah it's like when
you get old yeah but uh but yeah all
right yeah you know so what I thought it
was Wednesday
did you really for a minute for a minute
what's going on oh hold on Oh wait [__]
we're talking about we're talking about
yeah blood Vision I will say about I
like that the title of this one is like
specific because you know how we're
always complaining like a lot of the uh
titles of a haunting are kind of like
you know Echoes from the great yeah at
least you can remember this one but at
least you can remember this one and it's
an app title because even though other
stuff happens in it there is a guy that
has visions and they do indeed have
blood in them yeah it could have been
named like you know visions of the past
hand of the day
they call in Hand of the Dead did they
they had other ones like something like
something of the hand from the grave
yeah oh yeah yeah but see that's again
very specific but I like that this had a
specificity from the morgue that'd be
awesome it's about a hooker comes back
or it could be about a Decker file yeah
booty from the grave yeah
uh I'll give you a dollar if you can
find a porn version or a porn movie
called that I bet there is a movie from
degree okay
because there's probably like horror
themed porn too Ben says darn it I just
realized I forgot to bring my earphones
for my bus uh train trip today oh that
sucks put the subtitles on yeah if well
the subtitles don't come in until after
well after the baby I don't know I don't
know that much uh I don't I don't know
that much what do you call the thing
what do you call the thing when you talk
with your hands why can't I remember
thank you God yeah I've had mad cow
disease I'm proud I can't remember [__]
but it's like just as simple as [__]
things
but yeah so uh this was from season five
uh episode one I think can we talk for a
second about and I even wrote this down
like in the back of my notes and I
always make myself laugh because I write
the notes down really fast like while
we're watching it and then like the next
day when I'm reading them back for the
show I'm always kind of like holy [__]
that's funny that I wrote that but can
we talk about like the actor that plays
the teenager yeah the one that's it and
I was like one he has like the biggest
nostrils I was just kind of like the
whole time I was like I almost kind of
want to like stick my fingers in there
and like yank you know what I mean it
was like that yeah
and he also had like a weird beard weird
beard um that like I guess this came out
in 2012 this season okay and um I kind
of feel I associate that beard that look
with the 90s but I don't I don't know
what that was all about and then like I
was telling you last night I said one he
looks like he's in like a bad 90s Indie
band and two he always looks like he's
smelling a fart
[Laughter]
there's a certain look for that huh well
yeah well he's just always making a face
like he's always like you know well he's
acting you know he's acting and he's
[__] every time
[Laughter]
his nostrils are like three times bigger
than your nostrils yeah yeah and I have
big nostrils but this dude's nostrils
were like off the [__] chain it's
still a good episode it is this is
actually like a better episode it's all
like watching a movie
this is a good this is a good season
actually I feel like they were
deliberately trying to get more
cinematic in this one because I mean
they even changed up like the themes a
little bit like it still has you know
that the motif that it had before yeah
and the titles look all [__] cool
yeah but it sounds like a lot more
cinematic like it looks a lot more
cinematic and it looks like they um
spent some more money on it hand me that
right there yeah we're gonna share this
all right we're gonna share it yeah
we're gonna share this I gave you too
much yeah what'd you do how'd you do
that I wasn't thinking oh well you know
and what it is I had to tell it I had to
polish up off that thing of juice oh
okay so I gave you a little bit more
juice
okay that's right
Armory van Pier said I can't whoops I'm
like some like stupid thing popped up in
front of the chat I can't believe how
many haunting episodes there are so many
ghosts I know right yeah and we're only
um there's a lot we haven't covered how
many seasons is it was it like 12
Seasons
I got all the all the physical media
ones and a couple of the ones that you
can get about the season on um Amazon
Prime on Amazon Prime you can't buy all
the seasons but most of them I think we
bought season eight
yeah some of them they had up some of
them they didn't have up for sale some
of the newer ones yeah I don't know I
don't know why we've seen I think all of
them at some point or another because we
used to watch it when we had cable but
like whenever it was on some of those
Seasons come and go in terms of
availability yeah I don't know why it's
probably like a rights issue I would
imagine oh yeah there's not a room up
there I don't know
well I don't know they got room for
everything else so true I don't know but
they'll be like yeah season 15 it's here
and then sometimes season 15 will be
blank there's nothing there it's not for
sale yeah it's weird you know yeah it
might be licensing costs like they only
they can only like they rent the ability
to sell it that's see that's what I was
saying something like that that's what I
was thinking they'd only have it for
like a limited time because they have
all kind of deals like that like with
copyright and rights and everything like
that like see if any new ones have
appeared yeah I don't even did we even
ever finish watching all the all the
eight ones that we bought I don't think
so I don't remember if we didn't check
yeah but yeah I wanted it like I said I
was trying to go back and fill in the
gaps in like the old ones yeah that we
hadn't got to and I was like well we did
most of season one through four so we've
done a few from like season five six and
seven two but like this one we
definitely hadn't done and this was one
that I remembered mostly because like I
said the title was specific and I was
like oh yeah that's the one with the guy
that actually saw blood Visions so you
know uh you know good title so uh yeah
so this one actually takes place
in a suburb of Detroit
uh and we're following the Johnson
family and I'm guessing that's their
real name because they were all the real
people were on there they weren't like
in Shadow or anything they didn't say
what year this took place
um not that I remember it anyway but it
looks like it probably wasn't that long
before the show came out and that's this
show aired in 2012 because the I guess
like when they were doing the
reenactment the teenage boys like they
didn't look that much older than they
were supposed to be like in the
reenactment you know what I mean so I
mean because like the kid still looked
young like he still looked like 1920
something like that so I'm assuming it
was just like a year or two before 2012.
so at the very beginning of this and
this is kind of going along with what we
were saying about this season starting
to go more cinematic was that they did
kind of like a cold open or like a Flash
Forward where they showed like a scene
from the end with you know the exorcism
thing and everybody's like standing
around like really intensely I mean
everybody I have to say in this one like
the actors in this one man they really
went for it yeah they really were
they're trying to up the game
so they're just all like really
intensely like
they were like all screaming like that
and I was just kind of like okay yeah
the kind of like a documentary feel of
of one of season one through four is
gone by the by by the Time season five
comes around yeah it's straight up
monster movies yeah they're trying to
make it more like this movie yeah which
you can see why they were yeah it's all
right it's kind of like something other
than some of these new [__] you know
la la Llorona movies you know [__]
The Conjuring Universe yeah you can see
the Condor Universe I think well maybe
there's only a couple different ways you
could do these anyway that's true so and
I mean that's one of the things to copy
because those things are like make all
the money
what did the first Conjuring movie come
out I don't even [__] around I don't
know
they started to kind of feel like that
yeah
and like I said they they even they look
like they spent some money on the
special effects I mean they're not you
know Hollywood level but they're still
like pretty [__] good for TV
so yeah so they do this Flash Forward
with like the exorcism which I thought
was really funny and then they're like
six months earlier you know what I mean
uh so yeah so as I said this is the
Johnson family uh the mom's name is
Betty and she's married to a dude named
Bruce and I guess they've been married
for 20 years and they have two sons who
were like I guess they were like
teenagers or Brynn they said Brynn right
that was his name yeah I think that was
what his name was the guy with the
nostrils but like he the real guy didn't
look anything like the actor but um the
actor had big huge nostrils and a weird
beard and so um
and so uh he was the older one and I'm
guessing he was like an older teenager
maybe he was supposed to be like 17 18
something like that and then he had like
a younger brother named Dylan who was I
guess supposed to be
12 13. couldn't really tell I'm not good
at telling my kids ages uh so yeah
so apparently they moved to this big
rural house uh in a suburb outside of uh
Detroit it's like a big Farmhouse kind
of thing now The Farmhouse as far as I
could determine because I was writing
down the notes really fast it belonged
to Bruce's parents so Betty's
parents-in-law
and I guess for whatever reason the the
mom and dad like the the in-laws were
still alive but they had moved somewhere
else and they were like hey you guys can
either you can have it or you can rent
it or you can buy it from us or
something
so the family moves into
this rural house and they're all like
super jazzed about it and then I kind of
laughed because the narrator Anthony
call uh he says on their things he said
things seem okay for now but are they
man they got you on this case then no it
ain't gonna would it be funny if he said
that and then a second later he's like
it was okay the end and then the credits
run yeah it was all cool
nothing happened good night
I would love that that would be [__]
hysterical but yeah but are they no
they're not all right spoiler alert
so uh so Betty says they move into the
house and she's like it felt like really
homey she said it's an old house so it
was kind of quirky but you know nothing
seemed weird at first and obviously
because it was an old house needed some
work they said it was mostly cosmetic
work so they kind of uh were getting
started to work on that
so the first thing that happens I guess
is she goes down to the basement because
you know bad [__] always happens in the
basement and she's starting to like
organize it but she starts getting like
a really creepy feeling in there like
most people get in most basements
because basements are creepy like
inherently
and so she just figures well you know
the house is just old and I just need
time to get used to it it's no big
but then uh about a week later I think
they said Betty is like unpacking around
the house and starts hearing very
distinctly uh what sounds like a woman
sobbing and I believe she said it was
coming from the basement even though
obviously there's no sobbing women down
in the basement that would be a little
bit alarming
um and I don't think anyone else was
even home
and then yeah she said it sounded like a
woman in agony that's what she said it
sounded like and then there was like a
really loud scream like a woman
screaming and then like a louder scream
that for real I don't know if this is
what it really sounded like but on the
reenactment it sounded like somebody was
being [__] murdered or whatever
basements are so creepy that the Florida
banned them
my grandfather's house had one yeah
but it was half underground and half
above ground a little bit they're rare
here yeah you don't usually well like I
said I don't even know I think it's
mostly just because we're right at sea
level they would just they would just
flood all the time yeah because it's the
water is like right underneath the
surface
so um so yeah she was like kind of
freaking out at first and she was like
well maybe it was a neighbor
um or maybe it was like an animal you
know getting killed outside or something
like that so she runs outside to see if
anything is going on and she doesn't see
anything and she's like well I don't
know maybe I'm just you know tired and
I'm hearing things
you know how when you get tired and you
hear Randy yeah
[Laughter]
I can't count the number of times that's
happened I mean I'm sure it could happen
but I'm just saying
so uh so they say like over the next few
months they're kind of like settling
into the house or whatever and they said
well Bruce I'm always kind of interested
in what their jobs are Bruce is an
appliance salesman or Appliance
repairman or something like that and uh
Betty they said she worked full-time too
but and they said what she did but I
didn't hear it and I was just like she
does what and I was like well never mind
I didn't I was too lazy to back it up so
so she has a job too
now one thing that she said she started
seeing at first was she kept seeing like
movement out of the corner where I like
Shadows like moving but it looked like
at least on the reenactment it was like
Chad is like moving across the floor
because she said At first she thought it
was the cat like running around like the
furniture and stuff like oh hey Kitty
have you got a mouse or something like
that
and then she's kind of like uh goes over
there and the cat is just laying there
going what the [__] you looking at me
for I didn't do anything and you know
what I mean so so it's they just showed
it kind of like a little Shadow like
going shh like all over the floor that's
I guess what she kept saying
and then they kind of just went right
into the real scary [__] because
apparently she looks at the window I
don't remember if it was the kitchen
winner or the living room window or
whatever but she sees this old dude's
face like looking in at her and she's
like and I immediately knew that it
wasn't a real person because that
um window was too high up for there to
be just somebody standing there looking
in the [__] window
so it was like a scary looking old dude
like looking in the house which is a
ghost rape and the funny thing about
Betty because she was really on there
and they're like interviewing her and
stuff she's pretty uh chill about about
the ghost really well I mean she said
that well she believed in Ghosts to
start with so she wasn't like real
I mean she was scared but she didn't
seem like she was like super super
alarmed about it she was all chilled out
like she's a ghost expert well yeah
because she was just like well it's an
old house so of course there's probably
ghosts in it yeah
um you know and she's like and I was
actually more Curious than scared and
she was like oh that's interesting you
know what I mean which I thought was
kind of funny and yeah she did kind of
seem like not in a way that was like
obnoxious but she did kind of seem like
she uh she's like yeah she knew all the
stuff about ghosts but you know she had
she ends up having to question it later
on yeah
so a few nights later
the two sons who I said one of them was
like an older teenager and one was like
a younger teenager I guess uh Brenda
Dillon are their names and they're home
by themselves while uh their parents are
at work
so they start hearing like a banging
sound from the garage and they think
maybe somebody like is an intruder like
somebody broke into the garage or
something like that so they go to check
it out
and they open the garage door and they
say it looked like a um like a garage
that was kind of like a detached garage
sort of thing like a shed
and so they go out there and look and
they see this guy like he they just see
him from behind and he's like farting
around on the you know workbench or
whatever
and they said for a second they thought
it was their dad and they're just like
Hey Dad like what are you doing here or
something and then like the dude turns
around and it's not their dad it's like
it's that creepy old guy that was like
looking at their mom through the window
looks like he was panning for gold
goddamn white beard and [__] y'all
the minor 49ers he did kind of look like
that yeah
but yeah but he was just like farting
right it's like how sad is it that like
you you finally get to come back as a
ghost and it's like super amazing and
all you're doing is like tinkering
around in a garage like where are those
washers he was looking for stuff I guess
I don't know through those nuts and
bolts right I'm trying to figure out
he's trying to he's he's trying to
[__] separate metric from standard
I forgot to do it I forgot to do this
before I died
you own a Harley or a Buell or a Ford or
anything like that it would actually not
even afford anymore you know how [__]
frustrating dealing with [__] metric
and standard in the same house is [__]
[__] sorting out all the [__] bolts
and all the tools and [__]
yeah drive me [__] crazy I still got
a bunch of them down there I have to
sort I'm like I don't wanna maybe you'll
come back as a ghost one day and I'll
see you when they're doing that just
work God damn it [__] it I'll sort them
and then the next life
before I might be done with it
but uh but yeah so so they see this guy
and it's like I don't think they
initially
thought it was a ghost even though
one of the I think it was Bryn the older
one he said that it felt really cold in
there and like he felt all his hair
stand up on end but they just thought it
was like a dude like a dude had broken
into their garage and was farting around
in there
so their mom like comes home a few
minutes later like she pulls up in the
driveway and they're like Mama militia
there's like a dude in the [__]
garage or whatever and she's like oh I
wonder if that's the ghost and they're
like what what you know what I mean like
you knew that there's a [__] ghost in
the house
um you know it's just like or you know
it could just be the kids being drama
queens I'm not really sure
but um because they because the kids
said they saw it disappear they saw him
disappear right like after he turned
around and they're like oh my God that's
not dad and then he went just like you
know
so uh so yeah they they thought it was
kind of funny that she knew about the
ghost and she was just like oh yeah like
I've seen that dude before and she's
like pretty chill about it and um she
said something like uh Halloran says in
The Shining where you know it's just
like a movie and it can't hurt you yeah
that was her Theory anyway it turned out
it was wrong but you know
yeah you can only see him basically said
they can't touch you or anything yeah so
so she was just kind of like ah chill
out you know
so the next day apparently uh the boys
are exploring the property and
apparently there's this old because like
I said it's a big Farmhouse it was I
don't know how many how much land it was
or whatever but there was like an older
house or like a shed that was behind
theirs that their grandfather used like
to put tools in other vehicles and stuff
like that and usually Grandpa kept it
locked
like we had a padlock on it or something
like that but they said that they
noticed while they walked by that it was
unlocked which they thought was really
weird because Grandpa always like told
them to stay out of there and he always
kept it locked
so they were like well [__] it let's go
in here so which you know stupid idea so
they said they went in there and I get
like nothing weird happened like they
just said it was like super super cold
and then they just got like really
really creeped out and so they started
thinking yeah there's a [__] ghost in
here and then they ran out and then
after they ran out like the door slammed
by itself like once they were outside
and so Bryn starts yelling at the ghost
kind of like you know what do you want
get out of here blah blah blah and then
all of a sudden uh you know and the
younger kid like just runs off like [__]
this noise and like runs off into the
woods or whatever but then like after
Bryn was like yelling at the shed
um a branch like falls off a tree like
on him and almost like crushes his head
or whatever supposedly yeah supposedly
yeah maybe if I fell over there Branch
might have been just a regular little
twig that falls out of trees you know
wind blew yeah it was like [__] man that
Branch almost hit me
that [__] goes man he's trying to
kill me then they're showing a one that
big around in the [__] theater in the
[__] episode yeah it looked like one
that could have probably like like
cracked your skull or something
Carly says you died you come back just
to sort your toolbox yeah right I kind
of feel like that's yeah that job was
done you finished the job and you're
like [__] it I'll do that later you
never get around
you're tired man
so yeah so apparently they thought at
least that the ghost would try to drop a
branch on him because he yelled at The
Ghost and the ghost apparently doesn't
like that he's very very sensitive about
being yelled about being yelled at
um so Brynn said that he felt like an
energy or a negative something like run
by him into the woods and so when he
tells his mom Betty about it she's like
oh well maybe I was wrong about this
whole ghost can't hurt you type of thing
maybe they can actually interact with
people and maybe now my kids are in
danger because don't yell at ghosts kids
that's never a good never a good look
so later on that night she tells her
husband Bruce uh about the [__]
and saying I don't really feel safe here
anymore because you know the guys try to
crush our son's head with a branch now
to Bruce's in Bruce's defense he wasn't
one of those husbands that's usually on
this show we're just like what are you
crazy we can't move blah blah blah blah
blah you guys are just imagining stuff
he didn't seem like super I don't think
he had seen anything but he was kind of
like because she was like yeah I saw
some [__] and then now the kids have
seen it too and he was just kind of like
oh okay well I guess it's a thing then
and they actually unlike many of the
families on here they decide to move
so they didn't even like stuck or stick
around they were just like [__] it well
the thing about it is that this was
Bruce's parents house and I don't know I
don't think they specified whether they
bought the house from them or if they
were just renting from them or if they
were just letting them stay there or
something they did say something about
money so I'm assuming they were renting
it but Betty was just kind of like well
you know it doesn't really matter anyway
because it's like this isn't really our
house you know it's you're my in-laws
house and she's like and it was like 45
minutes each way to my job and that kind
of sucked like it was a long commute and
everything like that so it's like so
maybe we should just move because I
don't really I don't really like this
so uh you know so the hubs is like all
right they had enough money saved which
you know and they decided to move
so they got a newer house like a much
newer house in another uh suburb of
Detroit
but then unfortunately not too long
after they moved to the new house uh
Betty lost her job
and so obviously they don't have as much
money as they used to have and they have
all these expenses that had to do with
moving so Bruce actually had to end up
working a lot more to compensate like
until she could find something else
now as I mentioned Bruce is an appliance
repair I think it was an appliance
repairman right salesmen are prepared
yeah because I think he was going on
service calls so he was like repairing
people's appliances and whatnot
so uh for like a three to four month
period he said he was taking Bryn the
son Along on some jobs with him
now at one particular job that they were
out just in a random house I'm guessing
uh Britain has the first of many blood
Visions that's the one that he had
so apparently he's they they cleaned up
they were doing some Plumbing or fix a
dishwasher or whatever and he's washing
his hands in the sink and all of a
sudden he thinks that there's blood
coming out of the thing right and it's
like all over his hands
um and then he just started saying oh my
God
and then like um his dad is like no it's
just water you [__] freak or whatever
and so dad's like putting some he's like
look it's just water but then they
showed like Bryn said when I looked at
my dad's hands it's looked like he had
blood all over them and he said that it
didn't even feel like water that it felt
like really viscous and sticky like
blood as well
so uh so yeah and while I don't know I
wasn't clear on whether this was the
same day or not because he said that
this kind of happened over a few day
period but I guess when they were
leaving that job because he was wigging
out man the the sun was
um you know it was like everything's
blood oh my God and like then they're in
the truck like driving back home or
wherever I presume and um they pass a
lake and he's just like look the lake is
full of blood and his dad's like clearly
the leg is not yeah full of Blood come
on now um you know are you on the are
you on the drugs you know what I mean
he's experiencing The Exodus I guess so
yeah they did they never brought up that
possibility
the firstborn I'll start dying oh [__]
it's the end of times so uh so yeah they
passed the lake and that looks like
blood too and then he starts hearing
like this not entirely related but then
he starts hearing like screaming
he said he started hearing screaming
like every time somebody talks I'm like
really okay and uh I kind of laughed you
I wrote 10 of my notes it's under the
truck because they were driving the
truck and he was like did you just hit
something because I guess he heard some
thumping or like screaming or something
like I mean he was losing it he's really
losing it
um so yeah so he said for a few days all
liquid looks like blood which as you can
imagine
um makes life a little difficult uh as
far as like brushing your teeth and you
wouldn't be able to tell one liquid from
the neck and drink it oh yeah [__] I
never even thought about that because
people could [__] with you yeah so uh
yeah that's not great
Crowley City Crowley said he found the
mushrooms I guess so he got into his
dad's Dash but uh but yeah
[Laughter]
that would be so mean that sounds like
some [__] you would do no
it's like oh everything looks like blood
oh yeah yeah he says you'll never know
yeah gross but that's nasty so uh so Mom
obviously is uh a little bit worried
about this as you would be because like
I said Brent is like losing his [__]
mind he's just flipping the [__] out
everything looks like blood he's sitting
there at the table everybody's drinking
things and like they all look like
vampires because they all have like
[__] blood all over their mouths and
he's sitting there again looking like he
smells a fart and you know because he's
all disgusted by everything
um you know so Mom is just like are you
on drugs you know give me some but no
she didn't say that um or that he was
maybe like had schizophrenia or
something like that which is the first
thing that I would think actually
so she takes Brynn to the doctor they do
an MRI they do EKG they do all of all of
the acronyms but they can't really uh
find anything unusual and apparently
he's not on drugs uh so they're not
really sure what's going on
and um he said that after a while he
started taking it as you know like a
vision like a message from something
although he said the Visions kind of
suddenly stopped after a couple of days
and he was really relieved because now
he can finally take a shower without
feeling like he has blood all over
himself which you know again a little
upsetting
but then he's taking the first shower
that actually looks like water that he's
been able to take for a few days and
then he said he felt the shower curtain
move he said like somebody was raking
their fingers across it like that while
he was in there
and so he pulls it across but of course
there's nobody in there and then
evidently I don't know if he saw this
happen or if he just saw it already done
but he said on the mirror somebody had
written die now I was like rude so uh so
yeah
so he yells for his mom uh who's
actually she's on the phone I don't know
if this is what really happened but she
was on the phone about a job like hey is
that job still available yeah I can come
down he's like Mom there's like a blood
of the thing so it's like you know he
she had to like hang up and she's like
well facts I probably didn't get that
job now because now everybody thinks I
live with a lunatic so uh so yeah
now she starts to think well maybe the
doctors missed something you know what I
mean like maybe he does have some kind
of brain damage or something they didn't
see it uh so Brynn starts becoming real
depressed and withdrawn starts hearing
voices all the time that are also
telling him to die now all the time
which like I said uh rude
and um he said that it felt like the
weird [__] at The Farmhouse had like
followed them and I guess like the place
where they live now I think he said it
was 30 miles it was like a 30 mile
distance so he's like so whatever it was
that was at The Farmhouse evidently
followed us here
now at one point evidently was I can't
refuse in the bathroom or if he was in
his bedroom but he saw that same kind of
black shadow type situation like his mom
saw before like thinking it was the cat
and it kind of crawled up on the ceiling
and whatnot and then like it kind of
went like out of the room and it went
into the living room where the rest of
the family was sitting on the couch like
watching TV and they all saw it too
apparently so he's like look there it is
there it is and it's like it comes up on
the ceiling and they're like holy [__]
what the [__] you know what I mean they
didn't know what the [__] was going on
with that
um so which that would be a little scary
if you saw like a big [__] just kind
of shooting out and he's like look I
[__] told you I'm not crazy
so uh Betty it started that's the mom
she's starting to think that the
presents followed them so they call up
Bruce's mom who like I said owned owned
the old farmhouse that you know because
they live in a different house now but
they called about that and they're like
what the [__] was going on there that's
like following us 30 miles you know what
what the felt what the [__] so uh
Bruce's mom
tells them oh well there used to be this
old guy who lived in The Farmhouse and
he was a real piece of [__] like he was
a real like Angry cranky old fart and he
apparently got into a fight with I don't
know exactly what the details were but
they kind of showed it as like a bunch
of teenagers that were kind of like
partying on the land and the old guy
came over was like yo kids today oh my
lawn get off my lawn like pretty much
and um and the kids were like yeah go to
bed old man or whatever you know what I
mean and then like the guy uh was a
little bit it escalated quickly is what
I'm saying he like picks up a beer
bottle he's like what job can he like
one of the kids like across the face he
didn't kill the kid but he blinded him
um so you know like I said it seems a
little excessive
just for just for that so uh so yeah so
the girlfriend of the guy who got
blinded the teenager she went to the
cops and I guess they were gonna arrest
the old guy but it turned out that the
old guy not long after before he could
be arrested the old man
left that home left that home never
you guys know what we're talking about
it
yeah well I yeah it would be proud see
that's how my brain works all the time
like I'm constantly thinking of like oh
yeah other things like referencing other
things but so yeah so before the old
fart could be arrested
um he was apparently in a horrible
horrible car accident uh it broke every
bone in his body and it took him like he
died but it took like 24 hours so it was
like this excruciating uh thing so um so
they're saying well maybe that's what
the ghost in the house was because you
know he was he was a little bit mad
about how he died and everything and he
was a little bit mad like before that so
you know it's just like a cranky [__]
so Betty starts looking for a Paranormal
Investigator to help them out and she
basically was like well she's like it
was really hard to find somebody because
most of them just wanted a bunch of
money and it seemed like a bunch of
scammers and stuff like that
so it took like a long time to find
somebody that didn't look like they were
gonna grift you know
so he said meanwhile everybody is kind
of sleeping together in the living room
they don't really have a lot of money to
like to hire an investigator so that's
another issue
um and then there's a very kind of like
show-stopping scene where Brynn the
older teenager he kind of gets pulled
down and like dragged across the floor
like and they actually I think they used
that shot in the um in the opening
credit sequence like for season five so
if you see like the old like the teenage
kid going like ah being like pulled like
back like through this wooden floor
that's from this episode
and then apparently like he you know he
goes way down the hall and his mom's
like holy [__] you know as you would and
he kind of hits the wall at the end of
the hallway and then he lifts up his
shirt and there was like big scratches
you know with the Demonic thing big
scratches on there and he said not only
were they fresh scratches but he said
they felt like dirty or infected that's
what he said they felt like because like
I said the real kid was on there
so Betty ends up calling a Paranormal
Investigator named Samantha Harris from
I can't remember what the name of the
play was the Michigan Paranormal or
something something
I didn't have time to write it down uh
so she says yeah uh we need to do a
cleansing on that
and later on uh she apparently felt
really uneasy at her own house like
before she'd even gone to investigate
any of this and she apparently sees the
same black shadow in her house and she
surmises that the evil entity doohickey
whatever he is
um is is like trying to scare her into
like not helping the family right and
she's like you can't scare me you know
what I mean so she like yells at the
ghost but she said she was scared but
you know what I mean
so Samantha and her partner whose name
is Kyle uh they turn up to the Johnson
House the next night
now the family tell her about the crabby
old man
um that they saw but she thinks of
course it's guess what a demon
and she's thinking
see this was a little bit of a different
angle I thought because normally they
would say oh well it's just a demon
that's pretending to be that but she her
theory was that no this demon was at the
old place and the demon was what was
influencing the old man to act an ass
and then like when the old man cacked
then the demon was like looking for
another person to like infest you know
what I mean and so since the teenager
was there he's like oh well there we go
I'm just gonna go get in that kid and
[__] with him because now the old man's
gone and his Toy's gone now so
so uh so yeah
and uh basically she's like we don't do
something we need to nip this in the bud
uh otherwise it's gonna move on to
possession
so while they're all talking apparently
the demon uh is listening to what
they're saying and opens all the
cabinets
like all the cabinets open
at which point I kind of feel it's I you
know I don't believe in demons or
anything but I'm saying even if they did
exist
um I I feel like I've been like is that
all you got
like we're sitting here talking about
the demon that it's like oh I can open
all your cabinets I'm like big whoop I
can do that too like do something cool
because this isn't a demon no of course
this is a [__] Poltergeist
if you ask me yeah yeah what do like
have you have you been getting
um what do you call them uh chat because
I haven't been getting any I mean every
now and then oh okay there's not very
many people in there oh okay yeah well I
just thought something was wrong because
sometimes if it um if it stops if the
chat stops that means that it's gonna
drop a comment in the chat section
people that it's the stream is like not
working yeah stream should be good yeah
I mean it's so I'm streaming it here
yeah it's a green light it's fine
but yeah so the demon opens all the
cabinets whoa [__] okay there
you go okay thanks yeah I wasn't sure
like nobody was talking so I thought
something was the matter
um so according to the Paranormal
Investigator and this is something I
don't think they might have mentioned
this on another episode but I don't
remember it
but apparently olive oil drives out evil
yeah you can get it at Publix who knew
yeah so there must not be any evil
anywhere in Italy for example
you can put salt around the house you
can drop olive oil holy water delicious
it's all inexpensive you notice that
well yeah yeah it's not that would
really suck if like the only way to
fight a demon was like well you have to
buy this 50 000 golden crusted
Mercury you know depleting uranium
it's like how the [__] am I supposed
well you're just gonna have to live with
the demons so it's something you can get
from the grocery store water salt olive
oil yeah pretty much Sage Sage that's
another one you could get get a pack
well you couldn't find the things here
man [__] McCormick
that's good enough right
dude you should have got body yet if
it's cheaper yeah bigger box
oh my God I mean it's maybe goes just
like all the spices exorcism brought to
you by Goya
right
[Music]
this is the they we need to do like a
whole bit about that that would be like
so funny like a whole [__] sketch
yeah so uh so she got the olive oil like
I said this is the first time I've ever
I've heard like oil oil but I didn't
know they were talking about like olive
oil because I was like okay whatever
like you get some bread to dip in that
um and she's got the sage she's got
[__] feathers she's got all the
Catholic [__] I mean she's covering all
the bases right
so Kyle is anointing the door with olive
oil as one does in uh Bryn's room
and he said that he heard a voice say
get out now
which you know okay very Amityville
Horror
and he feels something grab his arm he
said
so meanwhile Samantha is salting some
[__] like in another room
and then Kyle comes in and is like uh
the thing just talked to me I think we
should get the [__] out of here because
this is like web of our pay grade
probably
um and they said oh my God
oh my God technical difficulties
well I'm just saying that yeah
uh so then they said that both her and
Kyle felt uh like movement and hatred I
don't know if they actually saw the
black thing like the shadow yeah but
they kind of showed them seeing it like
oh [__] like it was like like across the
wall or whatever but I don't know if
they saw it or not
so then at this point she introduces
something which is again something I
haven't heard of before but sounds like
pretty badass the Warfare Prayer
is that a real thing I mean I guess
there might be something they just said
it uh with Michael the Archangel Michael
maybe
it might be something like that ass kick
in prayer doing Warfare with the [__]
fallen angels and [__] yeah I guess so
but I guess that's where it is but yeah
she's like we need to do the warfare
prayer and I'm just like all right
badass
uh so at this point this is when we're
getting back to the scene like they
should in The Flash Forward at the
beginning with the super dramatic like
pray in action that they were all doing
like they were all standing around in a
circle and and then they were like and I
thought this was funny too because I
even wrote it down like the way the the
way that the narrator said it uh because
Bryn has to resist one final
attack yeah yeah
he said it just like that and I'm like I
like cracked up yeah
um sir telegraphing it that's the last
one
so halfway through the prayer they said
Bryn starts acting weird not weird weird
he was mostly just standing there making
like even more like weird farty faces
like he was making me more like his face
is
you know what I mean and I was just kind
of like that's all the demons doing huh
it's like he's just [__] with him but
yeah like and he said he felt like he
was gonna
throw up and uh while he's making the
silly faces and uh at this point this
isn't where in the notes I wrote dude
has huge nostrils and looks like 90s
Indie band also like he's always
smelling a fart that's you I read that
right there uh but yeah
so at this point if nobody levitated
nobody coughed up cherry pits nobody did
anything like that it just seemed like
he made some funny farty faces uh said
he felt like he was gonna throw up and
then they all yelled some and then there
was like some lights flashing and then
it was over yeah
it wasn't much phenomenon reported in
this really they saw it they saw
apparitions yeah uh I guess some
cupboards opened
uh he saw a bunch of blood
for several days that went on right yeah
and then like a possession
sort of like a sort of a possession
that's about it
so it wasn't real phenomenal packed but
uh it was a good episode though a lot of
hype in it yeah I mean well they kept
seeing the little the little black
shadow object yeah like a couple of them
saw that yeah
but yeah it's like demon went away
pretty easy uh actually like I said no
one got pitched against the wall or
nothing like that
uh so they all they're like oh well the
house feels nice and comfortable now so
they all like party and hug each other
the smell of sanctity yeah there we go
yeah
[Laughter]
got there for Breeze yeah
um and then they do like a scene toward
the end where everybody's like Yay
everything's back to normal and they're
all like sitting in the dining room like
one evening like eating a pizza or
whatever and then all of a sudden like
there's like a windy noise and they're
like
and then they're like oh the window's
just open you know it was like the end
of a bad sitcom yeah but so I thought
you know it's like sitcoms from the 70s
you stand like then they freeze frame on
like people laughing it was kind of
reminding me of that not quite that bad
but it was kind of like that so yeah uh
because I wrote windows open not a demon
hahaha that's what I wrote it then and
then
um this I thought I would comment on
this because this kind of is interesting
but I think that Samantha the Paranormal
Investigator lady
she called she uh compared a demon to a
tick yeah or a parasite like yeah it
attaches on to you yeah it was probably
significantly worse than a ticket
although uh ticks can give you Lyme
disease yeah so there is that I don't
buy it I well I don't believe in demons
he moved from one place to another and
it went with him and he was the focus of
it it sounds more like a mild
Poltergeist case to me
you know
yeah I mean not a haunting the hauntings
are usually location based now not
person based yeah and if it was a demon
then [__] the demons are Ultra powerful
man they're they're Fallen Angels they
can [__] they can turn the entire
city of people to Salt you know they can
do all kinds of [__] yeah what if they
do [__] like that yeah yeah what's up
come on up your game right
now they just opened some cabinets yeah
because that's a little girl maker dude
look like he's smelling farts
pretty much it yeah I'm like that that
really doesn't take much that really
doesn't take much you know what I'm
saying if this is a real case I'd say it
sounds more like Poltergeist like a mild
one
Poltergeist cases some sometimes
culminate in something that looks like
possession well like I said in the fact
that it did follow him and the thing
about this one too is that you know as
cool as this episode was it was a good
story and everything like that but a lot
of the stuff yeah some of them saw
Apparition type things like the old guy
and the black shadow and everything like
that but it did seem like a lot of it
though was subjective because a lot of
it was just the kid saying that they saw
seeing like visions of stuff yeah which
that doesn't that's not necessarily A
paranormal that could be a lot of
different things and what's missing from
a poltergeist case in this case is the
movement of objects it's usually lots of
movements of objects not many objects
moved in this and they were they were
apparitions and apparitions you know
ghost figures and black
little [__] Shadow things moving they
heard voices and screaming yeah that
kind of stuff is rare in Poltergeist not
it's not a reported as much
it's you know and in mine I didn't see
that particular one whether there was
some voice at the end and
we did see some distorted
like clear Spots You're not required
shirts there like all the sphere and
then like a blue haze
would come and go but I wouldn't call
them humanoid apparitions no
they probably could have done it it just
didn't do it
I don't know
black frog said and then a demon just
jumps through the window wouldn't it
have been funny I thought they were
gonna do this actually because like I
said they were trying to make it more
cinematic it seemed like so after that
whole thing at the end where it's like
oh they thought you know there was
another haunting [__] but they're like
oh we just left the window open haha you
know it's fine
um it would have been funny if like a
little demon had popped up around the
window and been like like I thought they
were
they didn't do that that maybe they
thought that was just going a little bit
too far like that had been a little bit
too cheesy
Omri vampire says Parsley Sage Rosemary
attacks yeah
I love that song actually yeah but uh
but you know that's kind of like uh the
the recipe for getting rid of demons I
guess all you need some olive oil and
some sage and
since like I said some bread to dip it
in your local Win Dixie
and get yourself some Demon fighting
[__] yeah that's all you need get you
some boiled shrimp
they love shrimp do they yeah they love
shrimp yeah I I never heard shrimp crab
legs
throw the water some drawn butter yeah
we might as well
might as well
um but yeah so that's pretty much the
end of that episode
um so what else do what what do we what
have we learned from this particular
episode nothing nothing
that that dude has huge nostrils it was
really bugging me the whole time I
should have looked it up because some of
the actors that are on haunting like
obviously they have IMDb Pages because
some of them have been in other things
and the dude that played Brynn on this
one was so familiar and I couldn't
figure out if I'd seen him specifically
before or if he's just reminding me of
somebody else for a second I thought he
reminded me of Matthew Lillard from
screen the Scream movies or you know
he's been in other things too but that's
where I mostly remember him from but
it's like that's not quite right but it
was somebody like that like somebody in
that Circle or somebody that was in
those movies or or those type of movies
like at that time period he kind of
reminded me of that and like I said he
looked very
I don't know why it just gave me like
the impression of like looking very 90s
even though this show came out like in
so I don't know and like I said he had
huge nostrils I mean that's not his
fault though it's not like you can
do anything about the size of your
nostrils really can you hmm I don't
think you can I didn't notice it
I think it was because well and because
the only photo it's really hard okay
it's really hard to find um making fun
of the guys no photos well he can help
it he can't open so making fun of me no
I'm not making fun I'm just saying that
they were just I was commenting they
were really big nostrils okay but um I
think some of it might have been because
he was making that face all the time and
so it looked like his nostrils were
flared so it probably made them look
bigger but also um it's really hard to
find Stills like photos from uh these
episodes because usually if you go
because you know each episode has like
an IMDb entry and usually they'll only
be like one photo and it's usually like
real shitty and low res and it's usually
not even a picture of anything like
exciting like it's not a picture of the
ghost or anything like that it's usually
just a picture of like you know a couple
of the actors just standing around you
know which is weird and the only photo
from this episode was actually an
exciting scene was the part where Brynn
gets dragged across the floor so that's
what I used for the um for the thumbnail
it's just so it's like his face real
close up and like his big nose and his
mouth is opening he's like ah you know
what I mean so maybe that's kind of why
maybe that's I got the impression that
he had like the big nostrils because of
that photo I don't really know
um but yeah so that was that that was
blood vision
and uh I guess
you seem like that's it wrap it up
in the show for 10 minutes
yeah I was trying to say other ships
there's nothing more to say about it all
right all right so uh yeah we're gonna
we're gonna wrap it up and uh go and do
some other [__] and we are we will be
back Wednesday night
which I think is going to be a cool show
this is going to be a cool show because
somebody recommended this to me a while
back and it won in the poll so Wednesday
night we're doing a show about
uh The High Priestess of blood Magdalena
Solis she is a Mexican serial killer
okay and there's also a cult angle this
is like back in the 60s all right and uh
it's a cool story like I haven't like
I've done like I started doing some
research on it yesterday
um I'm gonna do some more like before
the show but it's a fascinating story uh
how it came out but yeah so we will see
you guys then and thanks for dropping by
let's talk about haunting today we'll
see you guys on Wednesday evening good
night